DAVE: I'm pleased to
introduce Peggy Orenstein.
In addition to being
a bestselling author,
she's been named
one of the "40 women
who changed the media
business in the past 40 years"
by the "Columbia
Journalism Review."
Her last few books have
focused on topics related
to her growing daughter,
or are relevant to them,
and this book continues
in that tradition.
As the father of
a teenage girl, I
found the topic both
interesting and concerning.
Even though I started the
book with my daughter in mind,
along the way it
gave me insights
relevant to both of
my children, and I'm
sure you'll find
it insightful, too.
Please join me in giving a warm
welcome to Peggy Orenstein.
[APPLAUSE]
PEGGY ORENSTEIN: So I
have-- oh, yeah look.
I've got a microphone on me.
This is interesting,
because I have yet
to do an event where there are
more than three men present.
[LAUGHTER]
So this is sort of cool.
I wondered about this
coming to Google,
because I kind of figured
it was a little bit more
of a guy place to work, although
that might be a stereotype,
and I apologize if that's true.
But I was excited about that.
So I wanted to talk a
little bit about this book,
and how I came to do it,
and some of what I found.
And then I thought
we could just chat
if that works for you guys.
So I came to this book
really-- my previous book
had been called "Cinderella
Ate My Daughter."
And that was looking at the ways
that the culture was telling
girls, from the very youngest
ages, that how they looked
was more important
than who they were.
And I was looking at
that through a kind
of pop cultural lens.
And I was looking at it partly
because I'm a mother myself,
and I have a 12-- now
12-and-1/2-year-old daughter.
And after I finished that
book, I was going around,
and I was starting to hear
some stories that were really
concerning me about
the hookup culture
and about sexting and
about binge drinking.
And my first response
was to kind of go, ooh,
my child's little.
I don't have to hear this.
I don't want to hear this yet.
Parenting from ignorance
and fear, generally not
the best idea.
So I started sort
of digging into it.
And what I wanted
to look at was,
we're having this
umbrella conversation
in this culture
right now that's been
going on for several years
about assault on campus.
And it's a really, really,
really important topic.
But consent, it's a really low
bar for a sexual experience.
You know, like, I was not
assaulted is a really low bar
for a sexual experience.
And so I became
really interested
in looking at what was going
on in young women's lives
after yes, and what had
changed, what hadn't, how
they-- whether they felt more
in control of their experience,
whether they were more able
to create something that
was satisfying them,
whether they were more
able to articulate
their wants, needs,
and desires than
previous generations,
and whether some of
the dynamics that
were happening in
those relationships
were feeding into
the culture that
was surfacing around
coercive sex and assault.
So I decided to talk
to young women who
were between the
ages of 15 and 20,
because that's
sort of when girls
are becoming sexually active.
And I talked to girls
who were-- they spanned
a pretty broad
ethnic demographic,
but they were all middle class,
they were all in high school,
either going to college
or already in college.
And I particularly chose that
demographic because I wanted
to talk to girls
that we think of
has having opportunity,
and the kind of girls
that we think of as
being the beneficiaries
of the feminist movement.
Because if those
girls who were-- I
mean, the girls
I talked to, they
were-- if I had been
interviewing them
about their education,
their aspirations,
their professional
dreams, I would
have walked away so impressed.
And if these girls who were
leaning in all over the place,
you know, were toppling
in their personal lives,
I felt that we couldn't really
deny that there were issues
that we needed to address.
And what I found with them was
that while today's young women
felt entitled to engage
in sexual activity,
they didn't necessarily
feel entitled to enjoy it.
So as one young
woman I talked to,
who is a sophomore at an Ivy
League school said to me,
you know, I come from
generations of strong women.
And my grandmother was a
firecracker, and my mother's
super strong, and my sister
and I are really loud,
and that's our feminine power.
And then she proceeded
to articulate
a kind of series of
hookups that were
kind of demeaning,
depersonalized, not
very pleasurable.
And she said, you know,
I think we girls are just
socialized to be deferential
and not express our wants.
And I said, wait.
Five minutes ago,
you told me that you
were a really strong woman.
And she kind of hemmed and hawed
and she said, yeah, you know,
I don't think anybody ever
told me that that strong woman
image applied to sex.
And I began to think about
this disconnect between how
we talk about sex in the
culture and how we see sex
all around us, and how
the landscape is littered
with female body parts
used to sell everything
that we can possibly think
of, and the complete dearth
of honest conversation,
frank conversation,
real, authentic
conversation that we
have with young
women-- and young men,
but particularly young
women-- about sex.
And the whole idea of where
my previous book led me
to this book-- or
I was saying, girls
used to talk about
pretty, and how
it was more important
to be pretty
than to be anything else,
that had morphed into hot.
And girls were
sold hot, which is
a really narrow, superficial,
commercialized idea of what's
sexy and what's
attractive that tells them
over and over that how their
bodies look to someone else
is more important than how
those bodies feel to themselves.
And they're sold that in a way
that whereas I think parents
who are Gen-X parents or who
are Baby Boom parents, women
that age would have
pushed back against that
as self-objectification
or sexualization.
For today's young
women, that's sold
as a source of empowerment
and self-confidence,
and often is the
most important source
of self-confidence and power.
So it becomes much more
complicated for those girls.
For instance, as one young woman
that I was talking to said,
she showed me a
picture of herself,
and she was going
to a party, and she
had the requisite crop top and
little skirt and high heels.
And she said, you know,
I'm proud of my body,
and I never feel more
liberated than when
I'm wearing skimpy clothing.
And I said, OK.
And we talked about
it a little more.
And a few minutes later, she
said that a year previous,
she wouldn't have worn that
same outfit because she
was 25 pounds heavier.
And as she put it,
some jerky boys
would have called
me the fat girl,
and that would be bad
for my mental health.
So then I felt we needed
to have a discussion,
and have a discussion
with young girls about who
gets to be proud of
which bodies under what
circumstances, and how
liberating that idea of hot
really is if humiliation
and judgment lurk just
around the corner.
And what we know in
the culture of hot
is that
self-sexualization affects
girls cognitively,
psychologically,
and in a real bait-and-switch,
it affects them sexually.
Girls who
self-sexualize actually
report less power
in the bedroom,
less satisfaction, less
control over their experiences.
So there's this way
that I felt like, OK.
If the opposite were
true, if this was truly
creating a more powerful
situation for girls
in the workplace, in
education, in their sex lives,
I'd have to say, all right.
I'm just fusty and old, and
it's time for me to shuffle off,
you know?
But it seemed quite
apparent to me
that the confidence was
coming out with the clothes,
coming off with the clothes.
And whether we were
talking about porn,
whether we were
talking about pop,
whether we were talking about
fashion, what girls were
learning was that pleasing
others was more important
than their own pleasure,
that being desirable
was more important than
understanding their desire,
that appearing sexy was more
important than understanding
their own sexuality.
And one of the things that
I talk about in the book
is the way that we
need to, as adults,
change the way that we
talk about sex with kids
and broaden our
definition of sex
beyond virginity and
beyond intercourse.
Because when we talk about
sex as being intercourse,
we are-- and in fact, the
rates of intercourse among kids
have not changed.
They're sexually
active at the same age
as they were 20 years
ago, and they're sexually
active at the same rates.
However, that denies and
diminishes and marginalizes
the other forms
of sexual activity
that are taking place,
particularly oral sex.
And it makes it so
that those are not
subject to the same
rules about consent,
coercion, responsibility,
and respect.
It makes it into not sex.
So particularly where
oral sex was concerned,
I heard so many stories
about girls having, you know,
oral sex.
And when I say that,
I mean female on male,
because male on female was
a whole different situation
for girls.
But female and male, they
would describe as not sex.
That would describe
as no big deal.
And they engaged in it
for a lot of reasons.
It was to please a partner,
to gain popularity,
to feel a sense of
power, to feel desirable,
because they wanted
an evening to end,
and they wanted
a guy to go away,
and they didn't know how
else to make him go away.
But it was rarely something
that was in their own bodies.
And after a while, I
started saying to girls,
because I got sort of
frustrated by hearing
all these stories of this
one-way situation, what
if every time you
were alone with a guy,
he asked you to
go to the kitchen
and get him a glass of
water, and he never offered
to get you a glass of water?
Or if he did, it
was kind of like--
[SIGH]
You want me to, you know,
get you a glass of water?
You know, really begrudging.
You would never stand for it.
And they would say--
they would laugh
and they'd say, well, when
you put it that way, yeah.
And I said, well, maybe you
need to put it that way.
Maybe you need to think
about why for you it's
more insulting to think
about getting somebody
a glass of water than performing
a nonreciprocal sex act.
And it wasn't just about
girls getting theirs.
But I became very
intrigued with this idea
of what Sara McClelland,
who's a researcher
of the University of Michigan,
calls intimate justice.
And just like when
we talk about who
does the dishes in your home is
partly a political act as well
as a personal accommodation,
sex has those dynamics too,
and it can bring
up similar ideas
about equality, economic
disparity, mental health,
violence.
And we need to ask, when we
talk about girls and sex,
who gets to engage
in an experience?
Who's entitled to enjoy it?
Who's the primary beneficiary
of that experience?
And how each partner
defines good enough.
And those are
really thorny ideas
to explore for adult
women, I think.
But when we're talking
about girls' early formative
experience that's going
to be following them
through their lives,
you know, I just-- I
don't want girls' early
experiences to be something
that they have to get over.
And that was something that I
was just hearing way too much.
So as part of that
intimate justice,
we set girls up to
expect inequality
in their sexual relationships.
And I call that the
psychological clitoridectomy,
that we engage in.
So when baby girls and
baby boys are born,
we tend to name all of
our baby boy's body parts.
So at least we'll say,
like, there's your pee-pee.
Something like that, you know?
But with girls, we tend
to go from navel to knees.
And we just don't
name that great void.
And there's no better way to
make something unspeakable
than not to name it.
Then girls go into their
puberty education classes,
and they learn that boys have
erections and ejaculations
and girls have periods
and unwanted pregnancy,
which are not the same thing.
And we only see that sort of
internal diagram, you know,
that looks like a
steer head, of girls.
And it grays out
between the legs.
So we never hear the
word vulva, we never
hear the word clitoris.
And not surprisingly, fewer
than half of girls ages 14 to 17
have ever masturbated.
And then they go into their
partnered interactions,
and we somehow expect
that magically they're
going to be able to
articulate their wants,
their needs, their
desires, their limits,
and have those respected.
We think that they're
going to be able to think
they have a voice.
We think that they're going
to be able to advocate
for an equal relationship.
And it's really just
not that realistic.
And so again, you
know, I wanted to talk
about that idea of
virginity, and I
wanted to talk about the
idea of satisfaction.
Because one thing
that we know is
that we think of
satisfaction as being
one kind of monolithic idea in
that we know how to define it.
But in fact, young
women and young men
define satisfaction
very differently.
So young women are more
likely than young men
to measure their satisfaction
by their partner's pleasure.
So they'll say, if he had a
good time, I had a good time.
Whereas young men are
more likely to measure
their satisfaction by
their own pleasure.
So if I had a good
time, I had a good time.
What's interesting
is that that dynamic
remains the same for
girls when they're
in same-sex relationships.
So that's when we sort of see
an interesting transformation,
that in same-sex
liaisons, girls tend
to be orgasmic at the same
rate as heterosexual men.
Also really
interesting, and back
to the point of
virginity-- or actually,
let me skip back a second
before I get to that.
One of the things that gay
and lesbian girls would say--
gay and bisexual
girls would say to me
is that when they were with
other women, other girls,
that they felt that they
could get off the script.
And they used-- several of
them used that word, script,
which is the cultural script,
the media script, the porn
script, every script.
The sex education script.
And that when they
got off that script,
they were free to create
an experience that
worked for them, and
that wasn't dictated
by something outside
of themselves,
and it was a more creative act.
And that really stuck
with me as something
that I think that we
can learn from even
if we're in other sex liaisons.
The other piece of that was
when I was talking earlier about
virginity, when we
continually talk
about sex and virginity
as intercourse--
not because intercourse
is no big deal.
Of course it's a big deal, but
it's not the only big deal.
And it also marginalizes
and it completely
ignores the experience of
lesbian and bisexual girls.
And so I asked a
young woman, how
did you know that you
weren't a virgin anymore
when you've never had
heterosexual intercourse?
Oh, I get to make
this joke here.
This is so great.
She said, I had to Google it.
[LAUGHTER]
Guess what?
Google didn't know.
Guys, get on it.
So she said, there
was no answer.
And I said, well,
what did you decide?
And she sort of hemmed
and she hawed for a while,
and she said, you know, I
think I stopped being a virgin
when I had my first
orgasm with a partner.
And I thought,
just for a second,
what if that was the definition?
How that would shift our
whole conception of sexuality.
And it's this idea that
sexuality, especially
for young people, should be
this pool of experiences that
is about warmth and closeness
and affection and sensation
and communication and pleasure.
Not this race to a goal.
And you know, I
like to say, when
I talk to young people, who's
really more experienced?
The person who spends three
hours kissing their partner
and experimenting with these
ideas of erotic tension
and communication and sensation?
Or the person who gets wasted,
hooks up with a random,
and tries to dump their
virginity before they
get to college?
So it's just a way
to sort of think
about how to reframe this.
I'm just trying to decide
how much I want to talk,
and how much I want
to let you guys ask.
I mean, I talk a lot
about the hookup culture,
and what has changed
in recent years.
Young people did not
invent casual sex, right?
[LAUGH]
I heard that.
You know, please.
But what has changed is the
idea that sex arises out
of-- proceeds rather than
arises out of intimacy,
and that that's the norm.
And that was true in
colleges, and it was becoming
more true in high school.
So that whether
young women wanted
to be part of hookup
culture or wanted
to opt out of hookup culture,
or wanted to go in and out,
or however they
wanted to do it, they
had to define themselves
and their relationships
and their sexuality in
relationship to that culture.
And some young women
were really into it.
Some girls would come
in, sit down, and say,
I am so sick of women
being portrayed as victims
of the hookup culture.
I am a participant, I want
to be here, this serves me.
I don't want a
boyfriend right now.
I don't have time for
a boyfriend right now.
I want to focus on school, I
want to focus on my friends,
and I still want to have a sex
life, and this is how I do it.
Other women found it, you
know, unhygienic and just not
something that they
wanted to participate in.
But they all had to do that.
And what became
interesting to me
was not thinking about
hookups good or hookups bad,
relationships good
or relationships bad.
I'm not prescriptive that way.
That's not my job.
But what I did want to
talk about with girls
and what I did want
them to know was
what they were
likely and probably
were not likely to get
out of a situation.
So to know that if you're
going to go out and hook up--
and hookups, of course, are
not just lubricated by alcohol.
They are dependent
on it in order
to create what a
sociologist at Occidental
told me was called
compulsory carelessness.
So trying to anesthetize
yourself against feelings
so that you can go into these
sexual liaisons-- she said,
actually, her interview
subjects talk about sober sex
like it was an amazing unicorn.
So going into a
hookup, you'll probably
get an adrenaline rush.
You'll probably get a sense
of conquest, a war story.
You'll probably feel desirable
for a short period of time.
You'll get a warm body.
You might have some fun.
What you probably won't
get out of hookups
is good sex, or
the tools that you
need in order to practice
good sex or create intimacy.
So my hope was by surfacing
that and surfacing
how girls talked
about hookups was
to allow them to look at
what the realities were
of their choices, and then make
the choice from an informed
place.
I'm not telling
them how to make it,
but this is what
they need to know.
So at the end of the book,
I end in a co-ed classroom.
And I do that on
purpose, because I really
wanted to stop in a place where
boys and girls were working out
these issues together.
Because I do have great belief
that teenagers are thoughtful,
they are eager,
they're interested,
and they're capable of working
out their ethics, their values,
and learning to treat people
with ethics and respect.
And in part of that, in looking
at that section of the book,
I also looked at
other countries.
And one of the things that
was most interesting to me
was comparing the experience
of Dutch teenagers
to American teenagers.
And I looked at research
that showed how Dutch college
girls and American
college girls spoke
about their early
sexual experiences.
So these were demographically
very similar groups.
On every measure,
the Dutch girls,
whether it was fewer negative
consequences like pregnancy,
disease, regret, or enhanced
positive consequences
like knowing your partner,
preparing responsibly, enjoying
the experience, having
a positive body image,
every single measure, the
Dutch girls came out way ahead.
They embodied everything that
we hope for for our girls.
So what was different?
Well, in Dutch culture,
teachers, doctors, and parents
talk explicitly about sex
from the time kids are young.
In an age-appropriate
way, obviously.
And what was particularly
different was parents,
that while parents, American
parents and Dutch parents
were no less-- were no different
in their comfort levels
in talking about
sex, American parents
spoke exclusively
about risk and disease,
and Dutch parents talked
about balancing responsibility
and joy.
And I'll tell you that
thinking about that as a parent
really made a big
difference to me.
Because I think that before,
I would have reflexively said,
you know, I've talked to my
daughter about contraception,
I've talked to my daughter
about disease protection,
I've talked to my daughter--
because I'm really modern,
I've talked to
her about consent.
And then I would have
thought, good job, Peggy.
Job is done.
Now I know that that's not true,
and there's a whole other job
that I have to
figure out how to do.
And that's important
for boys as well.
And one of the-- I'll
tell you that one
of the most meaningful moments
in the classroom that I was in
was when a young boy, a high
school boy, raised his hand.
And they were talking about
something, and he said,
you know that baseball
metaphor for sex?
In baseball, there's
winners and there's losers.
So who's supposed to
be the loser in sex?
And I thought, you know, bingo.
Like, that was just
a small revelation,
but that boy, in
making that switch,
will go more into his
partnerships as a partner
rather than as an
adversary trying to score.
And actually, I don't even think
that girls in that metaphor
are the opposite team.
I think that girls might
be the field, right?
Saying It's not even that good.
So thinking about how to
replace that, I have--
and I'll end on
this, because it's
my favorite thing in the world.
Do you guys know Al Vernacchio?
Do you know who he is?
He did a TED Talk.
He's a sex educator
in Pennsylvania.
And he advocates
replacing the base--
and if you can do one
thing with your kids,
this is it-- replacing the
baseball metaphor with a pizza
metaphor, and here's why.
When we go out to pizza, we
have a shared experience.
First, we decide together,
you want to have pizza?
Yeah, let's have pizza.
Then we go to the pizza
place, and we order a pie,
and we negotiate.
We talk about, like,
maybe I like mushrooms
and you like pepperoni.
And so maybe we'll go halfsies.
Or maybe we'll have
mushrooms this time
and pepperoni next time.
Or maybe if you keep insisting
on pepperoni and I keep kosher,
I'm not going to go out
to pizza with you anymore.
You know?
It's a kind of endless
metaphor, but it is all about
having an experience
that's shared,
everybody's invested in
one another's pleasure.
You would never want
to go out to pizza
and have your partner not
care if your partner didn't
like the pizza you were having.
You want them to like the pizza.
You want to have an
enjoyable experience.
You want to be communicating.
And you can see, you
can take that metaphor
in all different directions.
But it's so far
superior in thinking
about how we can
talk to our kids
and raise them so
that they can think
about their sexuality in
terms of intimate justice,
and so that they can think
about engaging ethically,
responsibly, respectfully,
and joyfully,
whether their liaisons
last for 10 minutes
or whether they
last for 10 years.
So I will stop there, and I'd
be happy to take any questions.
Probably not the
discussion you think
you're going to have in the
middle of a work day, right?
[LAUGHTER]
I appreciate that you came.
Anybody have any thoughts?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So the question I
have is about the research that
compares the Netherlands
and the United States.
Is there research that
compares the Netherlands
to the best state in the US?
Because it seems like
it's such a small country,
and all the people
are very similar,
whereas the US is
huge and very diverse.
So I feel like it's maybe
not a very fair comparison.
PEGGY ORENSTEIN: Well, here's
why it was a fair comparison,
because it wasn't comparing the
demographic to a broad swath
of the United States.
It was comparing
two sets of girls
who were in college, who
were the same age, who
were the same ethnic
background, and who were largely
the same religious background
and the same economic
background.
So it wasn't
comparing Dutch girls
to the broad swath
of American society.
It was comparing the demographic
that I was particularly
interested in to
the demographic I
was particularly interested in.
But in terms of
states, you know, yeah.
There's huge diverse--
I mean, the truth
is that only 23 states in our
country mandate sex education,
and only 13 mandate that
it be medically accurate.
[LAUGHTER]
I know.
I mean, it's very sad.
And one of them-- I live in
California, and one of them
is supposed to be mine.
But it wasn't until last
summer that the city of Clovis
was found in violation of that,
because they were running films
in their sex ed class
that compared a sexually
active, unmarried woman
to a dirty old shoe,
and had the kids chanting--
I can't remember exactly
what they were saying now--
but they were teaching
them anti-gay slogans to chant
in school, in public school.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
PEGGY ORENSTEIN: Mm-hm.
You know, I'll say one other
thing about the Netherlands too
that's a sort of
broader idea about them.
But the one thing that
also really struck me
as a parent was Amy
Schalet, who wrote a book
called "Not Under
my Roof" and also
compared the Netherlands
to Americans,
she found some really
interesting things.
And one of them
was that we expect
American teenagers to
grow up by creating
a rift with their parents.
That we expect,
particularly girls,
we expect them to present
as the good girl at home,
and to lie either overtly or
by omission about what they're
doing outside of the home.
And I certainly saw
that with the girls
I talked to who were
always saying things like,
ugh, my father
thinks I'm a virgin,
or my mother has no
idea what I'm doing.
And in Holland, they're expected
to discuss these matters
in the family, they're
expected to grow up
in an interdependent
way with the family,
and parents use that
as a way to continue
to exert a kind of soft
control over the kids
so that they can reiterate
ideas about safety,
ideas about values,
ideas about respect.
And when I thought about
that, I thought, oh, my gosh.
I don't want my daughter to
have to grow up by lying to me.
I want to be on her team.
Well, at the same
time, I also realized
that that can be hard to do when
you're the parent, especially
in our culture.
And so I really advocate
also building the team.
Here's a good-- this
baseball metaphor works.
Build the team.
And I've been that
person where--
I have a friend
whose daughter was
becoming-- thinking about having
intercourse when she was 16.
And she asked me,
the mother asked
me to go out and have a
conversation with the girl.
And like everybody, I wanted
to fall through the floor.
I'm no different.
But I said, look.
Let's talk about this.
I know you're
thinking about this.
Let's talk about contraception.
Let's talk about
disease protection.
Let's talk consent.
And I'm going to ask
you some questions.
You don't have to
answer them, but I
want you to think about them.
Have you ever masturbated?
Have you had an
orgasm on your own?
Have you had an orgasm
with your partner?
Can you tell this partner
what you like and don't like?
Can you tell him no when
you're ready to stop,
and have him respect that?
Are you able to communicate
with him around these issues?
And if you answer no to those
questions, what is it that you
want out of this experience?
What is it that
you want for you?
Why are you doing this?
And she didn't really answer.
She just-- her eyes got,
you know, as big as my head.
And I don't know what
she ultimately decided.
But she's 24 now.
And we talk-- I just
talked to her yesterday.
We talk all the time.
We talk about her sex life,
we talk about her job,
we talk about her ideas
about graduate school.
We talk about everything.
And I feel like that
conversation opened
this door where she knew that
there was never going to-- I
was never going to
flinch, you know?
I was never going to flinch.
No matter what she told me, no
matter what we talked about,
I was there.
And I just think
to be able to have
that relationship
with your niece,
with your friends' kids, with
your own daughter, ideally,
is just a huge gift
in this culture.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
So you mentioned kind
of offhand talking
to children in age-appropriate
ways about sex.
One of the things
that I've learned
in talking with many
different parents
is that the definition
of age-appropriate
varies very widely.
Do you have any
guidance on-- that?
[LAUGHTER]
PEGGY ORENSTEIN: You
know what I would do?
I think what I'd like to
do is recommend a couple
books to you, because that's
a really long conversation.
And there are really
interesting books
that look at it from a
developmental psychology
point of view.
Deborah Roffman's book
"Talk to Me First"
talks about kids from
infancy to teenage years.
I mean, you know,
upper teenage years.
And Al Vernacchio,
the pizza guy,
has a book called
"For Goodness Sex."
And both of those books are
wonderful about guiding you.
Like, what do you tell
your two-year-old?
You know, what do you
tell your 10-year-old?
What do you tell
your 12-year-old?
It's really helpful from that.
But I do think that
there is a way that we
start from the get-go by
naming the body parts.
And I mean, I don't know if
any of you have a preschooler,
but preschoolers
masturbate all the time.
And one way to talk about
that with them is to say, gee,
you know, it's great.
It feels really good when you
touch your vulva, doesn't it?
And-- not but-- and we don't do
that at the Thanksgiving table.
We do that in
private in our rooms.
And, you know, it's OK to talk
about privacy, which is not
the same as secrecy,
and start building
that idea of bodily
integrity and pleasure,
and having control and
understanding of your body.
It's OK to say, you don't
have to hug Great Aunt
Nancy if you don't want to.
I'm not going to make you do
that, because that's pushing
you beyond a boundary,
and you should
be able to set your boundaries.
Nor am I going to make
her hug you, and I'm just
going to live with
the embarrassment
that Great Aunt Nancy thinks I'm
a really bad parent, you know?
So even things like that that
aren't necessarily-- I mean,
a lot of this is not about sex.
It's about creating an
atmosphere of trust,
and it's about creating an
atmosphere of ethics and values
in the same way that we do in
any area of our kids' lives,
and the way that we want them
to treat others, and in the way
that we want them to expect
others to treat them.
But I would recommend
those two books
about the actual,
direct specifics.
AUDIENCE: Can you
repeat the titles?
PEGGY ORENSTEIN: Yeah.
"Talk to Me First" by Deborah
Roffman and "For Goodness Sex"
by Al Vernacchio, which is
V-E-R-N-A-C-C-H-I-O, I think.
But if you look up pizza guy
and sex, you'll find him.
AUDIENCE: Nice, nice.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: So I have a--
PEGGY ORENSTEIN: I didn't
see you come up there.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
PEGGY ORENSTEIN: Ninja.
AUDIENCE: Stealthy.
I have a really good
friend who wants
to raise her children with
a culturally appropriate
for her sexual ethic.
They are very strong Christians.
I'm personally not, but she's
a really good friend of mine.
And one of her
challenges is she wants
to be able to have these
sorts of conversations
that respect the child,
the girls as women who
have these bodies, but has even
less resources for doing so
in a way within that subculture
where I think a lot of-- just
the idea of saying,
you know, oh, think
about the relationship you're
in and what you're getting out
of it, is not really the
conversation she wants to have.
I mean, if it's the reality,
that's a different thing,
but it's not the example
she wants to set.
So do you have any
advice for people
coming from that perspective?
PEGGY ORENSTEIN: That's
a very good question.
I mean, I think
that you can, again,
talk about ideas about
bodily integrity,
about respect, about
pleasure, about limit setting
that don't necessarily mean that
you have to go from zero to 60.
What's comfortable for you,
what's valuable to you.
I mean, I think you can have
those same conversations
regardless of when you expect
a young person-- I mean,
I don't know if what
you're talking about-- one
of the things that was true with
people who advocated abstinence
until marriage was that,
again, they were very focused
on intercourse.
And what we know about
that is that first of all,
it doesn't work.
Those kids have sex-- have
intercourse at the same rates
as other people.
They do tend to start
maybe a little later,
but it's a matter of months.
They have maybe fewer partners,
but they have much higher rates
of pregnancy and disease.
Way higher rates of disease.
We also know that they engage in
other forms of sexual activity,
particularly oral and
anal sex, at higher
rates than other teenagers.
So one thing to
understand for your friend
would be that that's
the likely outcome
if you take that point of view.
If you still want to
take that point of view,
you better be having a whole
other set of discussions
about what that means and how
kids can engage in ways that
would still-- where they
can express affection,
where they can
express sensuality,
that you feel jibes
with your values.
But it's a tough one, because
I mean, essentially, you're
educating your
children for ignorance,
you're educating your
children for risk.
You're putting your
children at risk
when you take that perspective.
So it's hard for
me to give advice
on how to do it
in a healthy way.
That it?
Oh, you have a question?
Dave.
[LAUGH]
DAVE: AUDIENCE:
In your book, you
mentioned something
called philophobia,
which is a new word for me.
So what is that?
How does it relate
to the subject?
PEGGY ORENSTEIN: That
was so interesting.
I was talking to this girl--
you're the first person who's
asked me about that.
That was such a
profound experience.
I was talking to this young
woman who told me, you know,
was like really swaggery
and really, like,
I have sex like a
guy, by which she
meant she didn't have to
have any feelings, which I'd
like to question in a minute.
You know, and she
could just object--
she objectified men the
way men objectify women.
She would tell-- you know,
I don't want that guy.
He's too fat.
And you know, I'm not
going to go out with that.
And she was like
really like the way
I would hope a male would
never treat my daughter.
That was how she
was treating boys.
And she felt really
good about that.
And then at the very
end of the interview--
we talked for about
two hours-- I said,
do you have anything else
you want to talk about?
And she said, philophobia.
And I said, excuse me?
She said, philophobia.
And I said, I'm sorry.
I don't know what that means.
And she said, fear of love.
I think that I have
a fear of love.
I do all of this,
but I am really
afraid of ever really
liking somebody and getting
into a relationship with them.
And it was really-- it was like
this really deep moment-- she
almost cried-- of, you know,
what was she getting out
of what she was doing?
And what wasn't she getting?
And thinking about her,
I felt like that idea
that how we should
learn to-- that progress
is somehow becoming as
disconnected as we can be.
Getting our sexual
hookups on Tinder,
or whatever people
are doing now,
that is a really low
road to equality.
That's a very low
And treating other
people like objects
is a very low road to equality.
And it's also clear
in research that one
of the things that teenagers
talk about, American teenagers
talk about, is that they
do want to hear more
from their parents, and
that they especially
want to hear more from their
parents about relationships
and the emotional side of sex.
And that that's a part that
they-- because what's happening
right now is that kids
are without sex education
in schools and in the face of
silence from their parents.
They go to porn, because
there it is on the internet.
And I don't want to, especially
in front of you guys,
I don't want to
demonize the internet,
but one of the
things it's done is
allowed porn into
your house 24/7,
really easily accessible,
increasingly explicit
because it's got to be
increasingly competitive.
And kids are able to access
it at ever earlier ages.
And when you look
at research on this,
there was a survey of
college students in England
that showed that 60% of them
said that they consult porn
in part as sex education,
even though 75% of them
know that it's about as
realistic as pro wrestling.
And I think it's
not really where
we want our kids to be
getting their sex education
because it's really not perhaps
the best image and vision
of female sexuality.
You know, it's another
performative space
that presents it as
for male gratification.
And I would hear
about this from girls.
They would say things to
me like-- oh, often they
would say, my
boyfriend wants to know
why I don't make the noises
like the women in porn.
And again, I got
kind of frustrated,
and my journalistic remove
faltered, and I said, look.
It's a movie, and a movie
has to have a soundtrack.
And if it doesn't,
it's a silent movie.
[LAUGHTER]
So people have to make the
noises so that there will
be a soundtrack on the movie.
That doesn't make it real.
They're actors, you know?
They're actors.
And that was kind of
a revelation to them.
On the more extreme
end of that spectrum,
we've seen a significant uptick
among teenagers in anal sex.
And again, I don't want to
demonize a particular behavior.
But we're talking, like I said,
about girls who have never
masturbated, never had
an orgasm on their own,
never had an orgasm
with a partner,
can't communicate effectively
with their partners.
And when you look into the
research, what comes up
is that it is driven--
it's a trend that
is driven by porn, pushed more
by boys because they want,
not as an act of intimacy with
a partner, but as, like, part
of that continuing to go in a
straight line in experience,
and kind of checking it
off your bucket list.
That the girls report,
unsurprisingly, that it hurts,
but that both-- this is
what was interesting to me--
both girls and boys blamed
that on the girls, because they
say the girls are-- they used
language like naive, flawed,
and unable to relax.
So again, you know, I
think it's really important
to get out front and
talk to kids about,
porn's vision of women is about
as real as "Real Housewives"
vision of marriage, you know?
But I also started feeling--
I had this conversation
with my own daughter.
And then like a
week or two later,
we were watching the
movie "Brooklyn,"
which is a great movie, right?
Fine movie.
Or maybe you don't like it.
I don't care.
But you know, it's a fine movie.
And there's a sex scene in that
movie that is very nondescript.
You know, it's just an
absolutely garden variety,
ordinary Hollywood
sex scene, which
is that the two characters
kiss for a couple seconds,
they rip off half their
clothes, they apparently
are having intercourse
for approximately seven
and a half seconds, and
then everybody's happy,
and it's done.
And it suddenly
occurred to me that that
wasn't very realistic either,
and that she's probably
going to see many more
thousands of times that image,
that sequence than actual porn.
And what impact does that have
on her idea about what sex
is supposed to be,
and who it's supposed
to be for, and who gets to
enjoy it, and all of that?
So I said, you know,
honey, you know
how in a movie when
somebody takes a cab ride,
they open the door
and get into the cab,
and then you see
them open the door
and get out of the cab
at their destination.
But you don't see
the whole cab ride,
because that would be,
like, the whole movie,
and it would be boring.
Similarly--
[LAUGHTER]
--when we see sex in movies
and on TV and in ads and in all
these places, or in
videos or whatever
you're doing, watching, we
don't see what really happens.
Hollywood has a
series of symbols,
which are kind of
outdated on what sex is.
And they throw
those up, and that
is supposed to signal to
us that sex has happened.
But it doesn't actually tell us
anything about what real sex is
or the experience of sex.
And I felt like that was at
least as important for kids
to understand as talking
to them about porn.
So a little ways from
philophobia, but there you go.
DAVE: Thank you very much.
PEGGY ORENSTEIN: My pleasure.
DAVE: We'll have
signing right up here.
PEGGY ORENSTEIN: OK.
Thanks, you guys.
Thanks for coming.
[APPLAUSE]